hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of all in the Masters I
believe in the fastest and most
effective way to grow a business is to
model the strategies of people who have
already done what you're trying to do so
today we're going to look at how a young
man who dreamed of becoming a
professional racecar driver change his
career after meeting the right mentor
and rose to the top of his industry this
is a story of Star Wars creator George
Lucas in the top three lessons that you
can learn from his success George Lucas
is an American film producer
screenwriter director and entrepreneur
he's the founder chairman and chief
executive of Lucasfilm and is best known
as a creator of the star wars and
indiana jones franchises Lucas's father
owned a small office supply store that
Lucas was destined to take over but he
had other plans he wanted to become a
professional racecar driver almost his
entire childhood was dedicated to cars
when he was in a near-fatal car accident
just days before his high school
graduation Lucas gave up racing and went
to college he enrolled in a university
of southern california school of cinema
television because he liked photography
and thought maybe this will be
interesting the program would change his
life he met Francis Ford Coppola at the
film school who served as his mentor and
inspired him become a producer director
upon graduation he committed himself to
doing films as his profession today
Lucas is one of the film industry's most
financially successful director
producers is estimated 2011 net worth is
3.2 billion dollars and he's received
numerous honors such as being named
among the 100 greatest Americans by the
discovery channel and receiving the
Lifetime Achievement Award by the
American Film Institute
by listening to his mentor and by
following his curiosity George Lucas was
able to rise to the top of his industry
to help your company rise to the top
here are three auction items that you
can learn from George Lucas action item
number one love what you do if you want
to find success as an entrepreneur you
need to be in business because you truly
love what you're doing you're not doing
it just to make money you're not doing
it because others expect you to do it
you do it because you want to do it and
you can't wait to wake up tomorrow
morning and do it again you may not be
excited about the results you're seeing
with your business so far but you have
to be excited about the actual work
you're doing if you hope to become the
next George Lucas of your industry Lucas
knew he never wanted to take over his
father's office supply store he didn't
even think of itself as a businessman
once he discovered his love of making
films that's all he wanted to do just
like he had done earlier in his life
with race car driving Lucas devoted
himself fully to filmmaking even though
filmmakers rarely made very much money
he wasn't in it for the money he was in
it because he loved it and he ended up
making millions in the process according
to Lucas my first six years in the
business were hopeless there are a lot
of times when you sit and you say why am
I doing this I'll never make it it's
just not going to happen I should go out
and get a real job and try to survive
you have to find something that you love
enough to be able to take risks jump
over hurdles and break through the brick
walls that are going to be placed in
front of you otherwise you'll stop at
the first giant hurdle
action item number to find something
you're great at to make a mark on your
industry you have to be really great at
something create a niche where you are
the absolute best at what you do and
start building a name for yourself as
you expand your expertise you can offer
more products and services but keep a
specialized focus so you can easily
separate yourself from everyone else in
your industry when Lucas enrolled in
film school he thought maybe that'll be
interesting he had no idea that Mickey
movies would become his calling all he
did was start following his interests in
the hope that it would lead him
somewhere he enjoyed when he first
enrolled he was interested in social
sciences anthropology sociology
psychology and photography he managed to
combine all of them into filmmaking am I
tapping into what he was curious about
success eventually became his according
to Lucas I'm a storyteller but to enable
me to tell my stories have had to
develop the necessary technology a lot
of people like to do certain things but
they're not good at it keep going
through the things that you like to do
until you find something that you're
actually seem to be good at talent is a
combination of something you love a
great deal something you can lose
yourself in something that you can start
at nine in the morning look up from your
work and it's ten o'clock at night and
something that you have a natural
ability to do very well action item
number three keep going entrepreneurship
is hard and you're going to have days
when you want to give up keep going if
you love what you're doing and you're
making a significant difference in the
lives of your customers you need to find
a way to keep going believe that what
you're doing is right and that things
will work out the dots will connect in
your future even if it doesn't make
complete sense right now trust that
you're on the proper path when Lucas
first decided to go to film school he
was told he'd never find a job
afterwards when he graduated and decided
to make a film about androids he was
told to come back when he was serious
and when his film about androids was
made not everyone was singing its
praises but Lucas pressed on and soon
became one of the wealthiest and most
well-known filmmakers in history
according to Lucas you simply have to
put one foot in front of the other and
keep going
put blinders on and plow right ahead if
you want to be successful in a
particular field of endeavor I think
perseverance is one of the key qualities
the secret is not to give up hope it's
very hard not to because if you're
really doing something worthwhile I
think you'll be pushed to the brink of
hopelessness before you come through on
the other side you just have to hang in
through that so remember love what you
do find something you're great at and
keep going to finish up this video I
wanted to share one of my favorite true
stories about George Lucas and some of
his best quotes Lucas wrote the
screenplay for Star Wars after being
inspired by Flash Gordon and Planet of
the Apes while writing it he thought it
was too wacky for the general public but
he insisted on finishing it when the
script was finished only 20th Century
Fox is willing to take a chance on the
movie in a groundbreaking move at the
time Lucas agreed to give up his
director salary in exchange for forty
percent of the film's back office take
as well as merchandising rights and
sequel rights breaking all box office
records and when in seven Academy Awards
Star Wars made Lucas an instant
millionaire as well as a household name
you
you
you
thank you for joining me for another
edition of modeling the Masters if you
like this video I want to see more
please give it a thumbs up below I'd
also love to hear your thoughts and
feedback if you want to leave a comment
under the video and stay tuned for the
next episode
you